[Music]
now live at four live local now and a
good afternoon to you thank you for
joining us at four i'm kirsten joyce and
i'm christian casadas deputies in night
county say they found dozens of frozen
puppies as part of their ongoing animal
cruelty investigation where they
recently seized 300 dogs the i-team's
david charns here now with more on this
startling discovery david yeah guys good
afternoon investigators say they found
the dogs in freezers and we're learning
the dog breeder was moving animals from
perramp to that location we brought you
live in amargosa valley now pro judges
order they are on their way to the
county animal shelter
once we move them we may discover things
we weren't aware of nike county
investigators say in addition to 300
living dogs they found quote dozens of
frozen puppies as part of this animal
cruelty investigation 0-4-2-1 in the
matter of
a bunch of dogs prosecutors announcing
the finding during an emergency court
hearing monday a judge ordering the dogs
be moved to the nye county animal
shelter we don't have enough room inside
the shelter we're going to be moving his
kennels and be putting systems in place
out here
behind the shelter to be able to care
for them here locally oksana higgins and
vasily platinov face animal abuse
charges for the care of the caucasian
shepherds bred and trained for
protection and sold for thousands of
dollars each platinum's attorney says
his client was moving dogs from pahrump
to the amargosa valley property he was
forced into
to moving these dogs from one
part of this one property owned to
another and that completely broke him
down
since last week the dogs have received
around the clock care now they'll be
moved and that could take days
they're all looking better just by
eating we're seeing a significant change
in behavior we're seeing a significant
improvement in their physical being
in general i think the time and food and
water and care is working out for them
now the sheriff's captain saying
donations are coming in not by the pound
but he says by the pallet the county has
set up a gofundme page to solicit
donations and they have a 75 thousand
dollar goal i'm david charns 8 news now
kirsten